as hundreds of millions of people around
the globe get in their vehicles every
day
the absolute last thing that anyone
wants is to get in a car crash
unfortunately reality strikes and there
are millions of crashes around the globe
every day these are stressful dangerous
and extremely costly in fact according
to the association for
safe international road travel countries
can pay
up to two to eight percent of their
entire gdp
on the cost of crashes so here's a
business question
how can a modern insurance company step
in
leverage data in ai and help alleviate
some of the time
and stressors that their customers are
paying on all of these crashes
let's say caitlyn has just been in an
accident the last thing she wants to
worry about is a month-long claims
process with her insurance company
luckily her insurer has an automated
claims processing workflow established
on their back end
which means just minutes after she's
been rear-ended she's able to provide
some basic information to get the claims
process going
another advantage is she's able to
gather and input the responsible parties
information
on the spot without having to track him
down later
leveraging her smartphone's camera she
can quickly document the damages and
then select the local shop she'd like
the repairs done at
the last step is to have the insurer
call her an uber
so that she can continue about her day
crashes are not
fun although insurers today have the
ability to make the
impact they have on their customers less
stressful
and they do this by ensuring that they
have complete mastery of how
all of their data interacts with their
customers
and their customers experience with ibm
insurers can deliver modern customer
experiences like this example
through a hybrid cloud and ai platform
deployable anywhere
to dive deeper check out the linked
videos and ensure to like and subscribe
to stay up to date